u.s special envoy
john kerry thank you very much for
talking to sky news happy to be with you
you have been engaged in an
extraordinary period of global diplomacy
is the international community
where you want it to be
just weeks ahead of cop26 well we've
made progress and i'm convinced that
cop26 will produce
an increase in ambition
uh globally
but we are not yet where the science
tells us we need to be
in terms of the level of that ambition
so it's rising
we're waiting for
some key countries to come in with
revised ndcs which is their
level of stated reductions
and we're hopeful
but there's still work to be done which
countries are you referring to because
in your speech you said that there were
some nations engaged in delivering bs
that's what you said to the young
activists which countries did you mean
well there are countries that
have in some cases i'm not going to get
into country for country
but there are some that regrettably
have just not been completely
forthcoming in terms of the levels of
reduction that they're making
and
one of the issues that we're discussing
in the context of the negotiation is
transparency and accountability
so that is not yet a closed
conversation
it's ongoing
but
most of us believe we have to have very
significant transparency with real
accountability
so that we're all in the same boat we're
all looking at the standards in the same
way
that's the fairest way to measure what
is happening
and i think that's what ultimately we
will we will wind up with
but look we're all in this together
every country has got to come together
we know
in terms of bs that
certain private sector entities over the
last 30 years
have fudged what they're doing talking
about big oil i'm talking about some
companies that are involved in the
provision of energy
who have not been candid
and and who hid even their own
information regarding
uh the science and regarding what they
knew
about the impact of global climate
so
you know we want everybody to step up
now this is not a moment for
incrimination it's a moment for
cooperation and that's what we're hoping
will take place
on that are you confident that the group
of 20 nations including china russia
india and others can come to an
agreement about the phase out
of coal for domestic use in time for
cop26 well i think that what people can
come to agreement on is the need
urgently
to not have unabated
production facilities where you're not
capturing the carbon
and
coal it seems to me the marketplace has
already made its decision about coal
no bank in europe no bank in america and
now possibly anywhere because of china's
recent decision not to fund coal
externally
i think that'll have a pretty profound
impact on
the readiness of finance to be available
for coal so
the marketplace is making a decision
about coal not us specifically but now
you have cheaper
and cleaner forms of energy
and that's where many countries are
going to go but alok sharma has said
that he wants to use cop 26 to consign
coal to history in your view is that
going to be possible we've only got days
to go i think that the cop process will
clearly define
uh that coal is going to be reduced very
significantly and ultimately
uh will not be a fuel of option for
countries anywhere and you expect china
and india and russia and others to be
happy about that well they're not going
to do that immediately obviously they
have
big plans that they've already put in
place
and some of them are new and i'm afraid
some of them are going to be around for
a while so the key to that
is the abatement they've got to be able
to capture the carbon
uh and put it somewhere and it and i
think the requirements globally are
going to be
increasing
that
people are going to have to transition
out of that into
some other form of providing energy and
now we know absolutely clearly without
any question
that alternative renewable sustainable
energy
is cheaper
than
the provision of coal
so just in the market terms it's going
to it's going to begin to be reduced
significantly but obviously coal is
the principle source of the worst damage
of the climate crisis
and it
hugely affects people's lives on a daily
basis all around the world we lose 10
million people a year
who die because of pollution and the
principal pollution
that uh that is involved in that is coal
our strained u.s china relations making
it harder for you to do your job
and convince china
to be more ambitious
uh the answer is yes it's been more
complicated because of other issues
which originally
are leaders
defined as being
outside of the entire lane of climate
climate was going to be treated on its
own because of its urgent
demands
but reality has crept in in the last few
months
and so there's been
a slowdown in our ability to be able to
move i hope now that's going to move i
think that
our presidents president xi president
biden
had a very constructive conversation
they did talk about cooperating and how
we could begin to find a way forward and
i think there will be further
discussions that
tackle some of the other issues between
us
in an effort to try to change the
dynamic change the relationship for the
better one of the places where we can
make the greatest amount of progress and
coordination quickly would be climate
and my hope is that we will still be
able
to find some common ground i will be
meeting with my counterpart
from china shortly
and we are both hopeful that we can make
some progress do you fear that china
will use the importance of tackling the
climate crisis as leverage for
increasing its power in relations with
the us well i don't think i i think
president xi is very concerned about
climate
and he is personally
engaged in all the decisions that are
being made about climate and i know
president xi has for some period of time
been deeply concerned and wants to try
to move forward on that
so my hope is that
we will be able to get some things done
before the cop i can't guarantee it like
what well i we're going to continue to
discuss the question of the next decade
and what we can do to try to reduce
emissions and
and treat this like the emergency it is
but it would certainly not be to china's
interest
to say
we're going to cut off our nose despite
our face
which would be the equivalent of saying
you know we're not going to deal with
you on this issue because we have this
other issue because the fact is
that not dealing with climate
is damaging to china itself and and is a
cost cost for their citizens who will
not have cleaner air and not have
uh cl you know
the safety of a long-term future that
comes by addressing the climate crisis i
think president xi knows that he doesn't
want to get caught up in that i hope
and
my hope is we'll find some common ground
what message will it send to the rest of
the world though if president xi does
not turn up to cop 26 in person well i i
can't you know i think
you must be concerned about that
no i'm actually i haven't really thought
about it very much uh to be truthful
with you i think uh 190 some countries
will come
and if they're 194 and not 195
there still would be a representation
and it's not going to be defined by
whether president xi himself i think
it's better for president xi to come i
hope he does come
i think it'd be great for him to show uh
the world that um
you know
china's at the table and at the highest
level and he's gonna
make announcements i think that's for
the better but i don't think the cop
will be deterred in doing its business
if one or two or three or five leaders
decide they're not going to get there i
think it's not the best thing
but this comp is going to go forward and
i think
you know the vast vast majority of
countries in the world are very anxious
to be part of
a moment where we really turn a corner
and we're heading in the right direction
on the climate crisis
why should developing nations in
particular with a higher reliance on
fossil fuels listen to nations like the
uk and the u.s
when they continue to grant permits
to drill for oil and gas on their own
soil
well we should not be doing new projects
in the judgment of many of us i think
what president biden has said is he's
not going to allow any public lands to
be used
but some companies have
leases that they've secured a long time
ago we're not going to be off of oil and
gas by tomorrow or next week or even
next year even as we're reducing
so it's not
you know completely illogical that
there's going to be a continuation to
some degree
that's a transitional process
it's going to happen over the next 30
years
we have to get about a 50 45 to 50
reduction in the next 10 years but that
doesn't mean zero instantly
so the key is are you on a track
that gets you
to
the 45 minimum reduction in the next 10
years and that gets you to net zero by
2050. that's what the science says we're
being guided by science here not
politics not ideology but arithmetic and
physics
and the conclusion scientists have drawn
about both of those
so
we will have gas being used as an
alternative for some number of years
gas is a quick 50 percent reduction in
the emissions from coal
or oil
but
unabated that is
but we need to do better we're going to
continue to be pushing and i'm confident
you'll see a continued tightening
president biden has decided by the way
and not a small incidental thing
that by 2035 the united states will be
carbon free
in all of its power sector so that means
no gas
no oil
no coal
uh by a
and and
a power sector
that is exclusively on renewable and
emissions-free energy but boris johnson
the uk government is continuing to grant
new licenses to drill in the in the
north sea is that the right thing to do
in your view well i i don't know what
the
time period is or the actual
you know details of that calculation i
think in general
we should heed the advice of the iaea
which is not to have new
fossil fuel projects that take you into
a long-term future we've got to be
paring down we've got to be shifting no
question about it
to what extent does it make your job
trickier when at home in the u.s members
of congress are struggling to even agree
to vote on a vast spending bill that
contains critical cash for combating
climate change well having spent 28
years in the senate i i understand
something about the cross currents and
the
flow if you will the ebb and flow of
congressional action
what happened today or yesterday or may
happen tomorrow
does not govern what the final outcome
will be
it affects the negotiating process it
affects the paring down of the piece of
legislation
the sausage making is not pretty
but in the end they're going to have a
sausage i believe
and
my hope is that it includes the critical
components of what we need to be able to
deal with the climate crisis
but always the legislative prerogatives
are such that you will see compromise
and changes one thing given up for one
thing accepted and you really can't make
a judgment about it until you get to the
final votes i want to talk a little bit
about moral authority in the united
kingdom and
in a recent speech
prime minister boris johnson rather
flippantly and jokingly referred to some
aspects of combating the climate crisis
as bunny hugging and greta tunberg used
her speech in milan to use that as an
illustration of a lack of seriousness
do you fully trust
that boris johnson is the right person
to help lead the global fight against
the climate crisis
well the proof is in the pudding right
in the eating of the pudding and we'll
get there i i think this is not a matter
of trust
[Music]
in the sense that we're making judgments
about whether we trust this or trust
that he's
committed to this
and he's publicly doing
major things in order to try to make
this work and i've been impressed by the
statements he's made
to date
committing
his government and the world to take
action and i think he's offering
leadership uh but in the end
um
you know we have to get there and and
it's the doing it's the actions we
all of us by the way same thing for the
united states i'm not asking somebody to
trust us right now we're asking you to
take note of what we're doing and trying
to do and what we're going to do
and and and that's what will determine
people which should determine the
judgments people will make about glasgow
and what happens there let's make that
judgment at the end of the
two weeks of our negotiations
as the western world transitions away
from fossil fuels it's going to require
a huge investment as you have often said
that will mean as well for ordinary
people that in the short term they might
face higher bills as they change their
vehicles as they change the heating
systems in their homes as perhaps they
pay more for fossil fuel-based energy
do you have sympathy with them when they
say that's a price i'm not willing to
pay sure i have huge sympathy with
people all over the world who've been
economically pressed
by
a process that has increasingly
created greater and greater inequality
in the world that has
hugely broadened the divide between
haves and have-nots
and in our own country i'll talk about
my own country
we have a completely unfair tax
structure that needs overhauling
that's not my bailiwick right now that's
not
in my lane so to speak
but
you know many people have spoken to this
unfairness donald trump spoke to it and
appealed to it in a certain way
and president biden is addressing it in
his legislation right now that is trying
to address this inequality and try to
bring things back together a little bit
but it does enter into the
question of environmental justice and
the fairness with which
this entire effort to deal with climate
is hopefully
not hopefully must not contribute to the
divide
must be sensitive to the realities of
life for people all around the world now
that said
properly implemented if we do this the
right way
this should not mean
economic dislocation and it should not
mean
a
hardship for people who
have to make choices about how to get to
work and you know driving their family
the doctor and so forth
what people are looking at here
are
is the development
and the support
for
alternatives that make life better
we lose 10 million people a year
to pollution
greenhouse gases
to to
the co2 that falls into the ocean
raises the acidity of the ocean warms
the ocean the warming oh you know 90 of
the heat that's rising on the planet
goes into the ocean so all of these
things actually raise the costs
for people every day
uh
we've spent billions upon billions of
dollars in the united states of taxpayer
money to do what to clean up after a
storm
to fight fires
to take the mud away after a big
mudslide that killed people
to to deal with the problem of floods
that have destroyed the crops of farmers
we have
about 50 billion dollars of cost
annually for children who are
hospitalized in america
due to environmentally induced asthma
that comes from the dirty air from the
pollution so
there are better alternatives here to
deal with day-to-day life challenges
that do not require
that the average person in the world is
going to have to pay more for these the
more we adopt
enviro the
efforts to deploy electric vehicles
the faster the price is going to come
down the more affordable it's going to
become but in the short term people are
going to have to pay perhaps more
out of pocket well right now today as
you and i are talking they're paying a
hell of a lot more for gas
right
and that's because we're not providing
enough alternatives for
you know for fuel
that in fact would be affordable right
now for instance green hydrogen
or
you know provision electricity
transition faster to electric vehicles
so you're not dependent on gas and gas
prices
that chew up the budget pretty rapidly
so i think people are tired of being
buffeted by these forces if we get on a
track to begin
to deal with the new energy economy
which is what we're talking about we
will have a far more stable economy
we'll have
lower prices ultimately
and
many collateral benefits
for instance
better health less cancer less disease
less hospitalization less complications
from covid or whatever it is for people
and
we will also have the ability to have
clean
high paying jobs in new sectors of the
economy that emerge as technologies come
online you know this is going to be
one of the biggest economic
transformations that we've had if not
the biggest since the industrial
revolution
we all saw what happened in the 1990s
when high tech came along with
telephones that are portable and with
desktop computers etc and it was a
revolution that was a one trillion
dollar market with a billion users and
it was huge
the energy market transition already has
four and a half to five billion users
it's going to go up to 10 billion nine
to ten in the next 30 years
and it's already the biggest market in
the world so we're looking at an
economic transformation that will bring
millions of jobs and opportunity we have
to build a grid in america the building
of that grid is going to create
unbelievable number of jobs for you know
electricians and plumbers and engineers
and heavy equipment operators and steel
workers and others because it's going to
take all of that to build out that grid
capacity same thing for building out the
uh you know electric vehicles you still
have steel demands you still have to
build the fundamental vehicle it's just
not going to have an internal combustion
engine it's going to have a battery and
fuel cells and so forth that's the new
future and in the build out of that new
future our economies are actually going
to do better than they do today
it's returning finally to cop 26.
when you
think about the scale of the crisis and
the urgency of solving it
do you ever feel anger
towards those nations and leaders who
are not willing to act i feel
frustration
and occasionally
um
you know i don't think it does any good
to get angry about it but it does good
to channel
efforts to change it and sometimes there
is frustration
in the length of time
and the slowness with which as a world
we have been moving to date i mean i
understand what greta and my own kids
and other people
are deeply frustrated
and
it's not inappropriate to be angry about
it you know
i think that
on a global basis
people have been put in jeopardy by
current practices and for the last 30
years we have known how bad it is 30 35
years
and still
people are moving too slowly
but it doesn't do you know i'm not going
to get lost in in uh
you know trying to
just voice anger
i'm going to try day to day to you do my
best which is what i'm doing
and everybody else here is doing
everybody here is committed to try to do
this in an effective way they're just
different views to some degree about how
fast they can go or how they can do it
and um
you know i consider myself lucky to be
able to be in the middle of that fight
that's that's
you know not
it's
i don't know sometimes i can reserve the
anger and scream
in the dark
but i'm not going to do it publicly
do you view cop 26 perhaps as an
opportunity for redemption
for a generation that failed to tackle
the climate crisis i haven't thought
about it that way no
but obviously
i mean are we that bad do we just need
redemption i think a lot of good has
happened when i was in college
the extreme poverty rate in the world
was over 50 percent today it's less than
10 percent
we're curing diseases we never thought
we'd cure smallpox polio
we have
uh perhaps on the brink of the first
generation of children being born
aids-free in various parts of the world
if you're a woman in the world today and
you're pregnant you're 50 more likely to
give birth to your child safely and that
child be able to eat and go to school
we're making advances
we're seeing less people die violently
today in the world than at any time
before in human history
so it's not all negative
and i don't view it as redemption for my
generation we
we uh we're a generation that
uh marched for civil rights and for
human rights and for environment and for
women's rights and we made a difference
through the years title ix in america
has seen us develop a soccer team that's
become
you know the women's soccer team has won
the world cup on numerous occasions that
wasn't possible 20 and 30 years ago in
america at least
so uh
you know i'm not here to apologize i'm
here to fight for the next step
you